ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS BAIT
BACKER FORGES RADFORD CUT BY
ADAM CORTESE DALLY GOD TORONTO
EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERZBERG WEST SO HER TADO JONES
CAN LONGER LAYERED. LLEVA THE
MON MCGUIRE MELINDA'S MAN
NEWMAN NIELSEN A SHOW OF VOGUE
PAN FORTUNE TINO ROSSI RUBIO
SKINNER STERN AMBERG QUAKE
OWSKI WINNER WILL. MEMBERS OF
THE QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL. WE STAND. WE'LL BE
LET THIS AFTERNOON AND IN THE
GALLERY. WLL BE LED IN PRAYER
THIS AFTERNOON BY SENATOR LAYER
LAYERED AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING
TO ASK YOU TO REMAIN STANDING
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR WIENER'S
CENTER ALERT. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. GOD OF MANY COLORS
YOU WANT TO SET YOUR RAINBOW
HIGH IN THE SKY. TO BE A SIGN
OF THE LIFE GIVING COVENANT
BETWEEN YOU AND YOUR CREATION.
LET THIS SYMBOL OF FAITHFULNESS
RESONATE WITH US AS WE RENEW
OUR RELATIONSHIPS WITH EACH
OTHER AND YOU DURING THIS
SEASON OF PRIDE. CREATOR GOD WE
THANK YOU FOR R. L. G. B. T. Q.
PLUS ALLIED. DIVERSITY BECAUSE
THESE COLORFUL EXPRESSIONS OF
LIFE LET US SEE YOUR MANY FACES.
ALTHOUGH MANY WE COME TOGETHER
AS ONE AND YOU. MAY ALL OF US
BE ATTENTIVE TO THOSE WHO ARE
EXCLUDED IN OUR WORLD. LET US
MANIFEST YOUR UNCONDITIONAL
LOVE. BY OUR EXTRAVAGANT
HOSPITALITY IN APPRECIATION FOR
THE DIVERSITY. EACH PERSON
BRINGS. LET US NOT BE
COMPLACENT BY OUR SILENCE IN
THE CONTINUATION OF
HETEROSEXUALS SOME HOMOPHOBIA
AND TRANSPHOBIA. AND WHAT A
SINGLE SWEET HONEY IN THE ROCK.
I AM SITTING HERE WANTING
MEMORIES TO TEACH ME. TO SEE
THE BEAUTY IN THE WORLD THROUGH
MY OWN EYES I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT MADE ME GROW INTO A
BEING FULL OF PRIDE I THINK ON
THESE THINGS FOR THEY ARE TRUE.
A MAN. PLEASE JOIN ME AND
SALUTING OUR FLAG I PLEDGE OF.
SIX SO JUST. THIS WILL. STRONG.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GONNA MOVED TO CONSIDERATION OF
SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTY NINE
IT'S FALL ITEM TWENTY TWO
SENATOR ADMIN ARE YOU PREPARED.
JUST ONE MOMENT WE'RE WAITING
FOR CENTER OF MEN TO GET READY
GET THE PODIUM READY FOR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS CONSIDER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTY NINE
BY SENATOR EDMUND RELATIVE TO
LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL
TRANSGENDER AND QUEER LGBTQ
PLUS PRIDE MONTH THANK YOU
SENATOR WHEN THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS- TODAY I
RISE AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE L. G. B.
T. CARCASS TO PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTION THIRTY NINE WHICH
RESIDENTS. WHICH RECOGNIZES
JUNE TWO THOUSAND ONE AS LGBTQ
PRIDE MONTH HAS MANY OF US KNOW
PRIDE WAS INSPIRED BY UPRISING
AT THE STONEWALL INN IN JUNE.
OF NINETEEN SIXTY NINE AND IT'S
PARKED A LIBERATION MOVEMENT. A
CALL TO ACTION THAT CONTINUES
TO INSPIRE US ALL TO LIVE TO
OUR NATION'S PROMISE. OF
EQUALITY LIBERTY AND JUSTICE
FOR ALL. IT IS AN OPPORTUNE TO
REFLECT ON THE TRIALS. OF LGBTQ
PLUS COMMUNITY HAS FACED AND TO
REJOICE IN THE TRIUMPHS OF
TRAILBLAZING INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE BRAVELY FOUGHT. AND
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR FULL
EQUALITY. OUR COMMUNITY HAS.
ACHIEVED REMARKABLE PROGRESS
SINCE STONEWALL LANDMARK
SUPREME COURT RULINGS HAVE
STRUCK DOWN DISCRIMINATORY LAWS
PROCLAIM MARRIAGE EQUALITY AND
ESTABLISH WORKPLACE FOR.
SECTIONS FOR LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE.
BUT IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
THERE'S STILL MUCH WORK TO BE
DONE. WE KNOW UP AND DOWN- THE
STATE THERE HAS BEEN AN ATTEMPT
TO FLY FLAGS OVER CITY HALL'S
AND STILL WE HEAR OUTRAGE AND
STILL WE HEAR PUSHBACK ON FROM
THESE BASIC THINGS OF FLYING
THE PRIDE FLAG. WE KNOW THERE
ARE MANY STATES IN WHICH LGBTQ
PLUS INDIVIDUALS STILL FACE
FUNDAMENTAL LACK THE
PROTECTIONS IN HEALTHCARE
EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT AND OTHER
PUBLIC CON **** ACCOMMODATIONS.
OUR NATION CONTINUES TO WITNESS
A TRAGIC SPIKE IN VIOLENCE
AGAINST TRANSGENDER AND WOMEN
OF COLOR AND OTHER GIANT GENDER
DIVERSE PEOPLE. WE CANNOT
FORGET THAT OUR COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN DECEIVED
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
COVERT NINETEEN AND MANY OF US
HAVE SUFFERED FROM FOOD
INSECURITY POVERTY AND
INADEQUATE ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE. WE CANNOT FORGET THAT THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY ARE BLACK AND
LATINO LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. HAVE SUFFERED THE MOST.
RIGHT MONTH WE WILL CELEBRATE.
WE WILL ALSO CONTINUE TO FIGHT
FOR EQUITY EQUITABLE RECOVERY
FOR COMMUNITIES CARE AND
FOREIGN INVESTMENT. IN OUR
COMMUNITY HEALING. WHO HAVE A
BAG HERE FOR YOU MEMBERS THAT
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO SHARE GIFTS
FROM THAT THE CAUCUS AND
THERE'S A QVC CODE ON THE
OUTSIDE SO YOU CAN BE ABLE TO
WATCH OUR CEREMONY OF. OUR
AWARDEES WHICH WILL BE DONE
LATER ON THIS WEEK AND RESPECT
OUT OF COVERT WE STILL WANNA.
RECOGNIZE THE- DAY
CONTRIBUTIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
OF THE L. G. B. TO COOK
QUESTION PLUS COMMUNITY. AROUND
THE STATE- AS WE CONTINUE TO
CONDONE INTOLERANCE AND- AND
FIGHT AGAINST INJUSTICE. I
ALWAYS REFLECT ON ON THE PRIDE
MONTH AND- THE RAINBOW FLAG AND
WHAT THAT SYMBOLIZES. WHEN THE
MOVEMENT FOR STARTED NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE THERE WASN'T ONE
SYMBOL THAT KIND OF UNIFIED
WHAT WHAT THIS WAS ABOUT. AND
AS FOR ANY MOVEMENT WHEN YOU
TRY TO THINK ABOUT WHAT A
SYMBOL WILL BE THAT WILL RALLY
PEOPLE TOGETHER AND SUMMARIZE
WHAT YOU'RE MOVING IS ABOUT.
THEY WERE YOU KNOW SHOULD BE
THE PINK TRIANGLE THAT WAS PUT
ON PEOPLE WHEN THEY WERE. SENT
TO CAMPS DURING THE HOLOCAUST
SHOULD BE THE LAN TO SAME
SIGNAL. WHAT WHAT SHOULD IT BE.
AND IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
GILBERT BAKER IN SAN FRANCISCO.
I WAS LOOKING OUT AT THE
CELEBRATION THAT JUST BEGUN AND
JUST SAW THE BEAUTIFUL RAINBOW.
OF EVERYBODY THAT WAS OUT THERE
AND THE JOY AND THE CELEBRATION
AND A PLACE TO BE WHERE THEY
COULD BE. AND AT THAT MOMENT
THAT THAT IS IT IT'S A RAINBOW
REPRESENTING ALL THAT WE ARE. I
REFLECT ON ALL OF US WHEN IT
WHETHER WHETHER YOU GET YOUR-
STRENGTH FROM WHEREVER YOU MAKE
IT AT THAT. THE SERVICE IN IN
IN MY CHURCH THIS WEEKEND WAS
ABOUT JOB IN THE STYLE AND THE
AND THE STORM AND HAVING FAITH
THAT YOU GET THROUGH THAT KIND
OF THING. AND FOR MANY OF US
SEEING THAT RAINBOW FLAG WAS A
SYMBOL THAT WE WERE WELCOME
SOMEWHERE- THAT FLAG WAS COULD
COME INTO EFFECT IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE AT THE YEAR I
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL. AND
I CAN TELL YOU GOING AROUND THE
COUNTRY AS A YOUNG PERSON
BEING. YOU KNOW IT WAS NOT OKAY
TO BE OUT YOU WOULDN'T DID NOT
FEEL WELCOMED OUT BUT IF YOU
SAW A LITTLE RAINBOW IN A
CORNER OF A STORE. YOU FELT
LIKE THAT WAS A PLACE YOU COULD
GO THAT YOU WOULD BE SAFE FOR A
WHILE. JUST LIKE THE GREEN BOOK
IN THE IN THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY WE HAD. PRIDE BOOKS
THAT YOU COULD GO AROUND PLACES
THAT WERE FRIENDLY FOR PLACES
THAT WERE COMFORTABLE. AND IF
THERE WAS THAT LITTLE RAINBOW
SYMBOL IT WAS LIKE A CODE YOU
KNEW YOUR OKAY. AND THAT OUR
OUR MOVEMENT HAS EVOLVED TO A
PLACE. WHERE WE HANG THE FLAG
BUT IT'S ABOVE CITY HALL AS IT
TELLS US WE DON'T HAVE TO LOOK
IN THE CORNERS. IN THE ALLEYS
FOR PLACES THAT WE MIGHT BE
SAFE. THAT VERY GUN. AT THE
VERY STREETS OF. TO SAYS THAT
WE CAN. TOO AND NOW WE CAN
CELEBRATE ALL OF OUR DIVERSITY.
IN WHO WE ARE. THAT'S WHAT THIS
PRIDE IS ABOUT THAT'S WHAT THE
RAINBOW CELEBRATES- AND I
INVITE YOU TO JOIN WITH US.
TONIGHT AT EIGHT PM. THE
CAPITOL DOME JUST FOR THE
SECOND TIME WILL BE LIT UP.
WITH THE OLD WITH THE RAINBOW
COLORS SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO COME
OUT AND WATCH THAT WE LOVE TO
HAVE YOU AND AGAIN. YOU CAN
LOOK AT THE Q. B. C. CODE AND-
INTO. AN ACCEPTING OUR GIFTS
AND THEN ALSO ADD ADD TO SEE
OUR NOMINEES. SO S. R. THIRTY
NINE AFFIRMS PRIDE MONTH. AS A
CELEBRATION OF DIVERSITY
DELIVERING ON THE PROMISE OF
FULL. EQUALITY FOR LGBTQ PLUS
FAMILIES LIKE MY OWN. AND AT
THE PRESENT TIME- THERE. AT THE
TIME I'D LIKE TO ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE ON THIS- MEASURE. THANK
YOU SENATOR EDMUND SENATOR
GONZALES. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND I TOO WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE LGBTQ
CAUCUS AND MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES HERE WHO EVERY DAY
FIGHT FOR NOT JUST THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITIES BUT ALL THE
COMMUNITIES THEY HAPPEN TO BE
OUR AMAZING INCREDIBLE
COLLEAGUES OF THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITIES THAT REALLY DO THIS
INCREDIBLE WORK WE NEED TO
CONTINUE SUPPORTING THEM. AND
THEIR EFFORTS- BUT LIKE MYSELF
AS A SENATOR FROM LONG BEACH
ONE OF BUT HAS A VERY LARGE AND
ROBUST LGBTQ COMMUNITY WE HAVE
OUR OWN HARVEY MILK PARK- THAT
IS THE CENTER OF CELEBRATION
FOR MANY LOCAL LGBTQ LITERATE
LEADERS AND EVERY DAY I AS OF
NOW I WANT TO ENSURE THAT I'M
FIGHTING FOR THEM THEIR VOICES
THEIR CHILDREN THEIR FAMILIES
SO WE CAN CREATE BETTER- AND
STRONGER GENERATIONS OF
EQUALITY FOR ALL. I THINK YOU.
THANK YOUS SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- HIGH
RISE AS A AS A GAY MAN AS THE
SENATOR WHO IS THE HONOR OF
REPRESENTING- THE GREAT CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO. HE'S ME AND
SUPPORT OF SENATE RESOLUTION
THIRTY NINE YOU KNOW WHAT I
THINK OF THE RAINBOW THE
WONDERFUL RAINBOW THE MASKS
THAT PEOPLE WERE IN TODAY AND
THE FLAG- I REMEMBER BACK TO
WHEN I FIRST CAME OUT AS A GAY
MAN IN NINETEEN NINETY- MANY
YEARS AGO NOW AND I REMEMBER MY
AUNT. WHO WAS AN OUT LESBIAN
WHO CAME OUT IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES WHEN BEING LGBTQ IS
STILL CLASSIFIED OFFICIALLY IS
BEING- MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION-
SHE GAVE ME A WOMAN'S HAND-
CALLED THE PRIDE- FREEDOM RINGS
THEY WERE THERE IT WAS LIKE A
RAINBOW NECKLACE THAT WAS A
THING BACK IN NINETEEN NINETY
IT'S NOT REALLY A THING ANYMORE
BUT IT WAS A TING BACK THEN
AND SHE GAVE IT TO ME AND AS
YOU SAID THIS IS A SYMBOL OF
OUR COMMUNITY AND YOU SEE WHERE
THIS. WITH PRIDE. AND I THINK
BACK TO NINETEEN NINETY- WHEN
THERE WAS NO. TREATMENT FOR HIV
AND MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY.
WERE DYING ON MASS WITH VERY
LITTLE ATTENTION. FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- THERE
REALLY WERE ALMOST NO- CIVIL
RIGHTS PROTECTIONS NOTING THERE
MAYBE THERE WAS ONE STAYED AT
THE MOST- THAT IS CIVIL RIGHTS
ON A FEW CITIES CALIFORNIA'S.
CERTAINLY HAD NO PROTECTIONS.
BY THAT POINT IN TIME- IT WAS
STILL CATEGORICALLY ILLEGAL- TO
BE IN A- LGBTQ PERSONS SERVING.
IN THE UNITED STATES MILITARY
WAS A CRIME STILLS PRE DON'T
ASK DON'T TELL WAS SIMPLY A
CRIME. AND WE WERE REALLY-
STRUGGLING AS A COMMUNITY AND I
THINK OVER THE LAST THIRTY
YEARS. WHAT'S HAPPENED IN TERMS
OF LAWS THA HAVE BEEN PASSED-
PARTICULARLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- AND JUST SOCIETAL
ATTITUDES TOWARDS OUR COMMUNITY
THE FACT THAT IN RECENT POINT
55% OF REPUBLICANS. SUPPORT
MARRIAGE. EQUALITY THINGS ARE
CHANGING BUT AS THINGS CHANGE
WE NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE. THAT WE
ARE SO NOT THERE YET. WE LOOK
ACROSS THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
AND SEE THAT THERE ARE. PEOPLE
STATES IN THIS COUNTRY. AND SAY
LEGISLATORS POLITICIANS WHO ARE
TRYING TO SCORE. POLITICAL
POINTS ON THE BACKS OF TRANS
CHILDREN. BY TRYING TO BAN THEM
FROM PLAYING SPORTS BY TRYING
TO BAN THEM FROM SEEKING HEALTH
CARE. THIS IS A TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THEIR POLITICIANS WHO THINK
IT'S SO IT'S ACCEPTABLE
SOMEHOW. TO TRY TO SCORE
POLITICAL POINTS ON THE BACKS
OF CHILDREN. THE MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN. IN OUR
SOCIETY. BUT WE CONTINUED TO
SEE HIV NOT UNDER CONTROL IN
VARIOUS PARTS OF OUR COMMUNITY-PARTICULARLY AMONG- IN THE
BLACK COMMUNITY PARTICULARLY IN
THE SOUTH WHERE WE'VE NOT DONE.
ENOUGH WE CONTINUE IN
CALIFORNIA TO CRIMINALIZE THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY- AND WE ARE AND
THE FACT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE TO DO THIS LEGISLATIVE
WORK. SHOWS THAT EVEN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE NOT QUITE
WHERE WE NEED TO BE. BUT WITH
ALL OF THAT SAID I AM SO PROUD
OF THE PROGRESS THAT WE MADE IN
SOCIETY AND PARTICULARLY HERE.
IN CALIFORNIA I'M SO PROUD OF
LGBTQ CAUCUS. A GROWING CAUCUS
OF MORE MORE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY FEEL COMFORTABLE
RUNNING FOR OFFICE AND ARE ABLE
TO GET ELECTED TO OFFICE NOT
JUST IN THE AMAZING CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO. BUT IN PLACES LIKE
STOCKTON IN PLACES LIKE
RIVERSIDE IN PLACES LIKE SAN
JOSE. ALL PLACES ALL OVER THE
STATE THAT HAVE NOT
TRADITIONALLY BEEN VIEWED. AS
LGBTQ EPICENTERS. BETTER
STEPPING UP AND EMBRACING OUR
COMMUNITY AND OUR COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF
YOUR SUPPORT FOR OUR COMMUNITY
REALLY- WARMS MY HEART KNOWING
THAT I AM SURROUNDED BY
COLLEAGUES. WHO ARE SO
SUPPORTIVE I ASKED FOR AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU TO SEND A PAN.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SENATOR
SAYS CHAIR OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
AM HONORED TO RISE IN
SOLIDARITY WITH LGBTQ CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF SR THIRTY NINE
RECOGNIZING JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
FIRST TWENTY POINT ONE AS LGBTQ
PRIDE MONTH. THE LGBTQ
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION
THROUGH THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS.
THEY ARE CALIFORNIA'S AND
AMERICA'S LEADERS ROLE MODELS
AND VALUE COMMUNITY MEMBERS OF
TODAY AND FUTURE. I'LL MAKE
NOTE THAT IN OUR OWN CAUCUS THE
VICE CHAIR OF R. EIGHTY I
THOUGHT THIS IS ALSO THE CHAIR
OF THE LGBTQ CAUCUS. AND THAT
WE ALSO HAVE ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
ALEX LEE WHO AND THE API CAUCUS
WHO ALSO IDENTIFIES LGBTQ. WE
HAVE MANY LEADERS IN THE API
COMMUNITY WHO ARE ALSO IN THEIR
FIGHTS L. G. B. T. Q. INCLUDING
JAPANESE AMERICAN ACTOR. GEORGE
TAKEI KOREAN AMERICAN COMEDIAN
MARGARET SHOW AND CHINESE
AMERICAN POET AND PLAYWRIGHT
KIT YEAH AND IT'S JUST A FEW
EXAMPLES. I ALSO WANT TO SPELL
IT ALSO RECOGNIZE THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
DESIGNATE TONY WONG WHO IS THE
ORGANIZATION'S FIRST ATI AND
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN. EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. WELL THE LGBT
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN AND
CONTINUES TO BE ESSENTIAL TO
IMPROVING. OUR STATE AND
COUNTRY ALL THE BBQ PLUS PEOPLE
ARE STILL FACING DISCRIMINATION
IN OUR SOCIETY TODAY. INCLUDING
THOSE WHO ALSO IDENTIFIED AS
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER. A STUDY
RELEASED IN TWENTY NINETEEN BY
THE HUMAN RIGHTS CAMPAIGN
FOUNDATION FOUND THAT EIGHTY I.
L. G. B. T. Q. PLUS USER AT
HEIGHTENED RISK FOR
DISCRIMINATION AT HOME AND AT
SCHOOL. STUDY FOUND THAT ONLY
19% OF A. P. I. L. G. B. T. Q.
PLUS YOU. COULD SAY THEY COULD
DEFINITELY BE THEMSELVES AT
HOME ONLY 29% SAID THEY COULD
SCHOOL. ALTHOUGH MANY PUBLIC
PRIDE CELEBRATIONS HAVE BEEN
CANCELLED DUE TO THE COVERED
PANDEMIC. ARE INCLUSIVE STATE
MUST INCLUDE CONTINUE TO
ENCOURAGE THE ADVANCEMENT OF
EQUALITY FOR ALL LGBTQ PLUS
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA IN THIS
NATION AND THIS WORLD- I KNOW
THAT THIS MIGHT BE OF GOOD
FRIEND FROM SAN FRANCISCO'S
POINTED OUT FORTUNATELY THIS
FIGHTS CLEARLY- THANK AN
ONGOING ONE IT'S CERTAINLY NOT
OVER. AND ESPECIALLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND VOTE FOR SR
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT AND- MEMBERS HI
STAND AS THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF SR
THIRTY NINE. AND I WANTED TO
NOTE THAT IT'S A FEEL
PARTICULARLY PROUD OF
CALIFORNIA UNDER GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAVING BEEN THE
PERSON THAT REALLY. STOOD UP TO
THE FOES OF GAY MARRIAGE BY
INITIATING WEDDINGS AT SAN
FRANCISCO CITY HALL ON
VALENTINE'S DAY AND I CAN'T
REMEMBER THE EXACT YEAR AND
THEN SUBSEQUENTLY CALIFORNIA
VOTERS AFTER FIRST REJECTING
THAT ACTION THEN APPROVING IT
AND ALLOWING. LOVE TO REIGN
SUPREME AND MARRIAGE FOR PEOPLE
WHO LOVE EACH OTHER- IN THE
LATE NINETIES I REMEMBER WHEN
MY DAUGHTER CAME OUT TO ME SHE
WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL AND A LITTLE
BIT THERE AFTER. THERE WAS- IF
SOME OF YOU MAY REMEMBER THE
SHOW THE TELETUBBIES AND ONE OF
THE KEY TELETUBBIES WAS TINKY
WINKY THANK YOU WORKING WAS
PURPLE. AND TAKE YOU WE KISSED
ANTENNA ALL THE TELETUBBIES
SAID TELEVISIONS IN THEIR
BELLIES AND TINKY WINKY CENTER
WAS SHAPED LIKE A TRIANGLE.
THAT CAUSED A PROMINENT
TELEVANGELIST COLD TO CALL TAKE
YOU WE CAN GET. SO I THOUGHT I
WAS GOING TO BE SO CLEVER I
WILL I GIVE MY DAUGHTER FOR YOU
KNOW WHATEVER THAT HOLIDAY WAS.
THAT YEAR I GAVE BIRTH THEY
TOLD. THE LOOKED TO ME TO MOM I
DON'T PLAY WITH TOY. THOUGH
MICHAEL. WHAT IS IT. SO YOU
KNOW THIS SIMPLE AND SHE'S LIKE
OH. SO IT'S JUST A
DEMONSTRATION OF HOW THE
GENERATIONS CHANGE AND MY
DAUGHTER AND HER WIFE JUST
BROUGHT ME MY FIRST GRAND BABY-
SO I'M VERY THRILLED ABOUT
THAT. BUT NOW I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT A MORE SERIOUS ISSUE
WHICH IS THAT. AS MANY STRIDES
WE'VE MADE AND THEY ARE
INCREDIBLE WE HAVE SO MANY
ELECTED LGBTQ PEOPLE WE'VE GOT
STEPHANIE BYERS SHE'S THE FIRST
OPENLY TRANS NATIVE AMERICAN
ELECTED TO STATE HOUSE. WE HAVE
A- GUEST I DON'T WANT TO NAME
SO MANY BECAUSE IN OUR IN OUR
LEGISLATURE IN THE SENATE IN
THE U. S. IN THE CONGRESS IN
EVERY STATE HOUSE. SO IT'S
INCREDIBLE BUT HOMOPHOBIA STILL
REIGNS. MARCH IN OUR COUNTRY.
AND IT'S LIKE SO MANY THINGS
IT'S MORE SIGNIFICANTLY AGAINST
WOMEN AND I'M NOT TRYING TO
MINIMIZE THE HOMOPHOBIA AGAINST
GAY MEN WERE AGAINST EVEN-
TRANSMISSION BUT WOMEN ARE THE
TARGETS OF VIOLENCE. L. G B.
T. WOMEN AT MUCH HIGHER RATES.
AND FOUR AS A PERCENT AS
COMPARED TO STRAIGHT WOMEN 44%
OF LESBIANS EXPERIENCE RAPE
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE OR STALKING
COMPARED 235% OF STRAIGHT
WOMEN. AND AMONGST THE TRANS
COMMUNITY 90% OF TRANS WOMEN
HAVE EXPERIENCED A VIOLENT
ASSAULTS SO THERE IS MUCH WORK
FOR US TO DO BUT AGAIN. I'M SO
PROUD OF THE STRIDES THAT WE
HAVE MADE. AND THAT I WOULD
NEVER HAVE TO HOPEFULLY NO ONE
WOULD HAVE TO HAVE THE
EXPERIENCE THAT I DID WHICH I
HAVE TALKED TO POINT TO THIS
FLOOR WHERE I LEARNED ABOUT MY
VERY FAMOUS AUNT. ELEANOR
TENANT TEACH TENANT ONE OF THE
FIRST TENNIS CHAMPIONS IN THE
US WHO WAS OPENLY MORE OR LESS
OPENLY OUT CONSIDERING THE
TIMES THIS WAS THE TWENTIES
THIRTIES AND FORTIES. AND I
LEARNED ABOUT- BY READING A
BOOK SHE WAS MY MATERNAL MY
PATERNAL GRADIENT I HAD NEVER
HEARD OF HER. BUT I CONFRONTED
MY FATHER IN THE CIVIL WE DON'T
TALK ABOUT HER. LATER OF COURSE
I LEARNED WHY BECAUSE SHE WAS
GAY AND WHEN I READ HER
OBITUARY IN THE LA TIMES IT
DESCRIBED THAT SHE DIED WITH NO
LIVING RELATIVES. SO HOPEFULLY
WE ARE PAST THAT POINT AND
THAT'S WHAT OUR QUEST IS AND
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO DO
RESOLUTIONS LIKE THIS TODAY AND
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO CELEBRATE
PRIDE RUN. AND THANK YOU. THE
YOU TO SET ARCHULETA. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO SHARE THE
MILITARY VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTY
NINE WHICH PROCLAIMS JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS LGBTQPLUS
pTHAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CULTURAL CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR
LGBTQ COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN
ORDER TO ACCURATELY REFLECT WHO
WE ARE AND WHO WE STRIVE TO BE
AS A STATE AND AS A NATION.
WHEN WE TEACH OUR CHILDREN TO
RESPECT ONE ANOTHER AND TO
RECOGNIZE THE COMMON GOOD AND
ALL OF US WE MUST MEAN TO
INCLUSIVELY TEACH THEM ABOUT
EVERY MEMBER OF OUR COMMUNITY.
NO MATTER WHERE THEY COME FROM.
IT MEANS ACKNOWLEDGING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR GREAT
STATE AND NATION THAT L. G. B.
T. Q. COMMUNITY MEMBERS HAVE
MADE IN EVERY FIELD OF ENDEAVOR
THE ARTS AND SCIENCES YEAH
DANA. PUBLIC POLICY AND THE
ARMED SERVICES IT WASN'T UNTIL
TWENTY ELEVEN THAT OPENLY GAY
LESBIAN BISEXUAL MEN AND WOMEN.
WHO WERE PERMITTED TO SERVE IN
THE MILITARY AND SINCE THEN
THEY HAVE LED THE WAY IN
OPENING DOORS OF OPPORTUNITY
FOR EVERYONE IN THE MILITARY
WHO THEY COME ACROSS AND
SERVING WITH HONOR PRIDE AND
DIGNITY. IN EVERY UNIT
DEPARTMENT OF BRANCH MEMBERS OF
THE LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY HAVE
EXCELLED. AND THEY MUST BE
ACKNOWLEDGED FOR THEIR COURAGE
PRIDE AND LEADERSHIP. AND THE
KNOWLEDGE IN WHERE WE HAVE
ADVANCED AND FURTHER PROMOTED
THE PRINCIPLES OF EQUALITY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL WE MUST ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR SHORTCOMINGS
BECAUSE THE WORK MUST CONTINUE
ON. WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO IN
A READY KATIE THE PREJUDICE AND
DISCRIMINATION OF OUR LGBTQ
PLUS COMMUNITY AND THEIR
MEMBERS AND TO THAT END. WHERE
EVER THERE IS A WAY TO ADVANCE
THE CAUSE TO BE QUALITY OUR
WORK ABSOLUTELY MUST CONTINUE.
WHETHER IT IS EQUALITY IN OUR
WORKPLACES FOR MARRIAGE AND
BENEFITS RIGHTS TO SAME SEX
COUPLES OR ALLOWING OUR LGBTQ
PLUS MILITARY SERVICE MEMBERS
TO PROTECT OUR STATE OUR NATION
OPENLY WITH PRIDE WE MUST
CONTINUE TO ADVANCE. THE CAUSE
OF EQUALITY BECAUSE WE- WE
QUALITY AS MUCH IN OUR FUTURE
TO OUR GENERATION AS WE DO TO
THOSE IN THE PRESIDENT WHO LOOK
TO OUR LEGISLATION OUR SENATE.
US HERE IN SACRAMENTO TO
SUPPORT EVERYONE EQUALLY AND
FAIRLY I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FROM STOCKTON FOR
INTRODUCING SR THIRTY NINE
RESPECTIVELY AFTER I VOTE. AND
TO THOSE WHO SERVED AND THOSE
ARE CONTINUING TO SERVE A JOB
WELL DONE. I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND BOTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR CAFIERO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY THIRTY
NINE WHICH DECLARED THE MONTH
OF JUNE IS LGBTQ PRIDE. MARSHA
P. JOHNSON ONE OF THE GAY
ACTIVIST CREDITED FOR PUSHING
BACK AGAINST POLICE BRUTALITY
AGAINST THE NEW YORK GAY
COMMUNITY WHICH SPARKED THE
STONEWALL RIOTS ONCE SAID. HOW
MANY YEARS HAS IT TAKEN PEOPLE
TO REALIZE THAT WE ARE ALL
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AND HUMAN
BEINGS IN THE HUMAN RACE. SADLY
WE STILL DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THIS QUESTION ACCORDING TO
DATA BY THE F. B. I. HATE
CRIMES AGAINST SEXUAL
ORIENTATION OR THE THIRD
LARGEST CATEGORY AFTER RACE AND
RELIGION EVEN HERE IN THE
PROGRESSIVE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY FINDS ITSELF THE
TARGET OF HATEFUL BIGOTED
RHETORIC AND ACTIONS TO THIS
VERY DAY. I'D LIKE TO SHARE A
RECENT EVENT THAT HAPPENED IN
MY DISTRICT KING SOOPERS CITY
COUNCILMEMBER JOEL HURTADO
PROPOSED A VERY SIMILAR
RESOLUTION TO DECLARE JUNE AS
PRIDE MONTH AND RAISE THE PRIDE
FLAG AT CITY HALL. DURING THE
CITY COUNCIL MEETING HUNDREDS
OF PEOPLE INCLUDING THE HATE
GROUP KNOWN AS PROUD BOYS
DESCENDED UPON THE KINGSBURG
CITY HALL FOR MORE THAN FOUR
HOURS OF PUBLIC COMMENT. SADLY
MOST TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE RED TO THE
RESOLUTION AND THE SAME VILE
AND HATEFUL WORDS MANY OF THEM
USING RELIGIOUS REFERENCES.
DESPITE THE HEARTFELT PLEAS FOR
SUPPORT IN THE ADVOCACY OF
COUNCIL MEMBER TO.
COUNCILMEMBER HER TADO
PROPONENTS OF THE RESOLUTION
WERE SIGNIFICANTLY OUTNUMBERED
AND IT FAILED TO PASS IT IT
EVEN FAILED TO GET A SECOND
BITE FROM A FELLOW COUNCIL
MEMBER. THIS IS WHY THIS
RESOLUTION IS SO IMPORTANT TO
ME PERSONALLY BY DECLARING JUNE
AS PRIDE MONTH WE ARE SENDING A
MESSAGE TO THE LGBTQ PLUS
MEMBERS OF OUR SMALL
COMMUNITIES SMALL RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS. LIKE COUNCILMEMBER HER
TITLE. THAT YOU ARE LOVED YOU
ARE SUPPORTED AND WE VALUE YOU
WE MUST LIFT UP AND CELEBRATE
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY AND EDUCATE
OTHERS THAT IT'S OK TO BREAK
NORMS AND BE WHO WE ARE AND
THAT WE ARE A STRONGER PERSON.
FOR DOING SO I WENT I THINK
GOOD CALL FROM STOCKTON FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION TODAY
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR
EARLIER THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT I THINK FOR MANY OF
US THAT ARRIVED HERE IN THE
SENATE. ARE WE NEVER THINK THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE PART OF
HISTORY OR THAT SOMETHING WE
DID AS AN INDIVIDUAL. WORLD BE
SOMETHING THAT IS PART OF A
LARGER MOVEMENT WE THINK IT
JUST MIGHT BE A DIFFICULT
SITUATION THAT WE FACED
OURSELVES AND MANY TIMES ALONE.
AND MADE A DECISION IN THAT
CONTEXT THAT REALLY MADE A
DIFFERENCE IN ADDED WITH OTHERS
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGED THINGS.
IN TO BUILD ON WHAT WAS SAID
EARLIER. AS ONE OF THE OLDER
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE WHEN I
GRADUATED FROM COLLEGE IT WAS
ILLEGAL TO BE GAY IN ALL FIFTY
STATES. ILLEGAL YOU COULD BE
ARRESTED OR CITED IN ALL FIFTY
STATES MUCH LESS JOB
PROTECTIONS. OR ANYTHING ELSE
AND- IT'S BEEN INTERESTING THAT
MANY SENATORS HAVE REFERENCE TO
STONEWALL INCIDENT AND YET IT
WAS NOT DOCTORS NOT LAWYERS IT
WAS NOT ELECTED OFFICIALS IT
WAS REALLY RANK AND FILE PEOPLE
THAT DIDN'T THINK THEY HAD MUCH
TO LOSE. THAT SORT OF STARTED
DOWN THE STREET OF STANDING UP
AND CHANGING THINGS. AND YOU
KNOW I WAS A JUST BECOME A
COUNTY EMPLOYEE. IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES WHEN SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY BECAME THE FIRST
COUNTY IN THE UNITED STATES TO
BAN DISCRIMINATION AMONG ITS
EMPLOYEES ON THE BASIS OF
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE WHEN THEY
DID THAT THAT WAS A REMARKABLE.
FEELING OF FREEDOM OF NOT
LOOKING OVER YOUR SHOULDER A
FEELING YOU COULD BE CLEAR
ABOUT BEING YOURSELF. AND WHEN
THE FIRST MARCHES IN MY HOME
TOWN HAPPENED IN THOSE YEARS.
WE HAD MORE DEMONSTRATORS THAN
WE HAD MARCHERS WE HAD TO HIRE
PRIVATE POLICE OFFICERS TO
MARCH WITH US FOR OUR SAFETY
JUST MARCHING IN PUBLIC. DOWN
THE STREET. IN IN ROOM. IN THIS
ROOM. WAS A DRAMATIC MOMENT IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES THAT
REMOVED THE SODOMY LAW FROM
CALIFORNIA WAS DEADLOCKED HERE
TWENTY TO TWENTY. BUT DEADLOCK
HAD TO BE HELD FOR HOURS FOR
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR TO FLY
IN FROM OUT OF STATE TO CAST
THE TIE VOTE. TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. AND FOR THOSE OF US
THAT LIVED THROUGH. THE AIDS
CRISIS THERE CERTAIN PARTS OF
IT THAT WERE REALLY PUBLIC BUT
AS SOMEBODY WHO WAS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF AN AIDS
AGENCY AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
EPIDEMIC BEFORE THE DRUG
COCKTAIL THERE WERE CIVIL
RIGHTS ISSUES THAT HAPPENED
WITH IT I CAN'T TELL YOU THE
TIMES. THAT A FAMILY THAT WAS A
STRANGE WOULD SWOOP INTO TOWN
AND SWEEP UP HALF OF A HOUSE OR
WOULD GO TO THE HOSPITAL AND
DENIED VISITING RIGHTS TO THE
SPOUSE IN THE LAST DAYS OF
SOMEBODY'S LIFE. JUST BECAUSE
THE RIGHTS MARK WHO RECOGNIZED
HIM I THINK THAT IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE WE HAVE BIG
DEBATES. ABOUT INCREMENTAL
CHANGE AND WHAT TO DO WHEN
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN THE
SUPREME COURT ACTED IN VERMONT.
AND SAID THAT THEY HAD TO HAVE
DOMESTIC PARTNERS BENEFITS
BASED ON SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND
THE QUALITY. AND VERMONT
LEGISLATORS EVEN THOUGH IT WAS
UNDER ORDER FROM THE SUPREME
COURT LOST THEIR SEATS IN THE
NEXT ELECTION FOR VOTING FOR
THAT. AND WITHIN A MATTER OF
YEARS DOMESTIC PARTNERS BECAME
THE CONSERVATIVE VIEWPOINT.
WITH REGARD TO MARRIAGE
EQUALITY. AND SO IT IS SO
IMPORTANT THAT EVERYBODY BE
CLEAR. STANDUP AND I THINK IT
IS EVERYBODY THAT MADE THIS
HAPPEN THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN A
CADRE OF PEOPLE THAT STOOD UP
AT THE BEGINNING OR ALONG THE
WAY OR CLEAR. BUT IT WAS TOO
MANY PEOPLE AND WE SAW THE
BROAD SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM.
THAT IS REALLY MADE THE
DIFFERENCE AND- IT IS NOW I
SPENT. TWO THE EXTENT OF DAYS
THIS WEEKEND. IN SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY DOING SEVENTEEN
THINGS NOW THAT WE CAN DO
THINGS AND I WENT TO THE GROVER
BEACH CITY HALL. AND SAW THE
PRIDE FLAG I WENT TO THE- GROW
GRANDET CITY HALL AND SAW THE
PRIDE FLAG. BUT I WENT TO THE
GALA DIVERSITY CENTER IN
DOWNTOWN SAN LUIS OBISPO. IT
HAD ITS SIGN DEFACED AND
DESTROYED JUST TWO WEEKS AGO.
AND STOOD WITH THEM. TO LET
THEM KNOW. THAT THEY WERE NOT
ALONE. AND THAT IS ALL STILL
THE EBATE OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
NOW SO THIS RESOLUTION IS
IMPORTANT. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
CONSTANTLY. PUTA STAKE IN THE
GROUND TO SAY WERE THERE WITH
COME A LONG WAY BUT WE STILL
HAVE THINGS TO DO SO HARD
PROBABLY ASKED FOR AND ONLY
FOCUS. ON SR THIRTY NORTH THANK
YOU SENATOR MEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AS PRESIDENT. I WANT
TO THANK THE L. G. B. T.
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS FOR BRINGING
THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD- LIKE
MY COLLEAGUES I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SR THIRTY NINE.
WHICH IS FUNDAMENTALLY
CELEBRATION OF THE GREAT
PROGRESS THAT WE HAVE MADE IN
THIS COUNTRY AND IN THIS STATE.
PROGRESS THAT WE EVEN SEE AN
ORANGE COUNTY OF ALL PLACES THE
LGBT CENTER OF ORANGE COUNTY
JUST CELEBRATED ITS FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY. CITIES LIKE IRVINE
ANAHEIM COSTA MESA AND LAGUNA
BEACH AND YES EVEN HUNTINGTON
BEACH ARE NOW FLYIN THE PRIDE
FLAG IN CELEBRATION OF THIS
MONTH SO YES PROGRESS IS
HAPPENING YES IT IS SO
DELIGHTFUL AND EXCITING AND I'M
PROUD TO STAND AS AN ALLY WITH
THE LGBT COMMUNITY. AS A MEMBER
OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
CAUCUS BUT ALSO JUST AS
SOMEBODY WHO CARES ABOUT THE
FUTURE THAT MY KIDS ARE GONNA
GROW UP IN. BUT LET'S MAKE NO
MISTAKE WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO. THERE ARE THOSE WHO
WANT TO TURN BACK THE CLOCK ON
PROGRESS THERE DOES THAT WE
SEEK TO DIVIDE US BASED ON WHO
WE ARE OR WHO WE LOVE. AND SO
AS LEADERS IN THE STATE'S BODY
LET US NOT FORGET OUR MISSION
TO TRY TO UNITE PEOPLE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT LOVE IS LOVE TO
TRY TO DEFEND THE GAINS WE'VE
MADE AGAINST THOSE WOULD TRIP
WHO WOULD TRY TO TURN BACK THE
CLOCK ON PROGRESS I URGE- I
VOTE. ON SR THIRTY NINE. THANK
YOU SENATOR DORADO. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT AS CHAIR OF THE
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IT IS
MY HONOR TO RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SR THIRTY NINE I AM
PROUD TO HAVE GROWN UP IN THE
UNION THE HOSPITALITY FOOD
SERVICE HOTEL WORKERS. CLEARLY
ONE OF THE MOST IF NOT THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE UNION ESPECIALLY ON
LGBTQ RIGHTS THAT'S HOW I GREW
UP IN THE LABOR MOVEMENT
ALONGSIDE. MEMBERS LIKELY JONES.
DURING PRIDE MONTH WE RECOGNIZE
THE RESILIENCE AND THE
DETERMINATION OF SOME IN THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE FOUGHT.
AND CONTINUE FIGHTING TO SIMPLY
LIVE THEIR LIVES REALLY AND
AUTHENTICALLY. L. G. B. T. Q.
LATINOS ARE MAJOR CONTRIBUTORS
ALSO AND EVERYTHING FROM ARTS
AND POLITICS AND THE SOCIAL
JUSTICE MOVEMENTS FROM THE
FAMOUS MEXICAN PAINTER FRIDA
KAHLO. TO JOSE JULIO SALARY OF
THE FIRST OPENLY GAY CANDIDATE
TO RUN FOR PUBLIC OFFICE IN
THIS COUNTRY. WE ALSO APPLAUD
SYLVIA RIVERA FOUGHT FOR THE
INCLUSION OF TRANSGENDER PEOPLE
INTO THE LARGER MOVEMENT FOR
GAY RIGHTS. ND THEN WE FAST
FORWARD AND WE HAD JUST
RECENTLY THE HONORABLE JOHN BAD
AS THE FIRST OPENLY GAY SPEAKER
IN THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER DICK.
THE FIRST OPENLY GAY
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICER OF OUR
STATE AND LET'S NOT FORGET TO
CELEBRATE OUR LEADER WHO HAS
BEEN BOTH SPEAKER AND PRO TEM
OF OUR SENATE SENATOR TONI
ATKINS. THE PRIDE MONTH AS WE
RECOGNIZE THIS PRIDE MONTH AS
WE RECOGNIZE THE MANY
CONTRIBUTIONS OF LGBTQ PLUS
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS OUR NATION.
AS A CAUCUS WE REAFFIRM OUR
FIGHT AGAINST ALL FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION AND INJUSTICE.
EVEN THOUGH HISTORIC SUPREME
COURT RULINGS IN RECENT YEARS
STRUCK DOWN. REGRESSIVE LAWS
AND AFFIRM THE RIGHT TO
MARRIAGE EQUALITY IN SECURED
WORKPLACE FROM WORKPLACE
PROTECTIONS FOR. INDIVIDUALS
THERE HAVE BEEN RECENT EFFORTS
TO ROLL. IN SOME STATES LGBTQ
INDIVIDUALS STILL LACK
PROTECTIONS FOR FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS THAT MANY OF US TAKE FOR
GRANTED. WE ALSO CONTINUE TO
WITNESS THE TRAGIC SPIKE IN
VIOLENCE AGAINST TRANSGENDER
WOMEN OF COLOR. AND YOUTH WHO
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY RESTS AT
RISK OF SELF HARM. I'M STILL
HAUNTED AS MANY OF YOU ARE BY
TRAGEDY SUCH AS THE PULSE
NIGHTCLUB SHOOTING IN ORLANDO
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN OR FORTY NINE
PEOPLE WERE SENSELESSLY
MURDERED AND FIFTY THREE
INJURED. BECAUSE THEY ENJOY
WE'RE TRYING TO ENJOY A NIGHT
OUT. THE ONLY FAULT WAS
DECIDING TO ATTEND A GATE
NIGHTCLUB THAT EVENING. SO AS
WE CELEBRATE LGBTQ PRIDE MONTH
WE MUST ALL BE DILIGENT AND
STEADFAST IN OUR COMMITMENT TO
HELP AND VIOLENCE AND
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST LGBT
COMMUNITY. ALL COMMUNITIES SO
WE CAN SURE JUST AND EQUITABLE
AMERICA FOR ALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I US SUPPORT SR THIRTY
NINE THANK YOU SENATOR
EXCEPTION- CALM WATER. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS TO
SUPPORT S. R. THIRTY NINE IN
SOLIDARITY WITH OUR LGBTQ
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. YOU KNOW
LAST WEEKEND I VISITED THE SITE
OF THE COOPER DONATH RIOTS- IT
HAPPENED ACTUALLY IN MY
DISTRICT AND THE RIDES- WERE IT
WAS A SMALL UPRISING IN
RESPONSE. TO POLICE HARASSMENT
OF L. G. B. T. Q. PEOPLE IN
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE THAT WAS
TEN YEARS BEFORE THE STONEWALL
RIOTS AND THIS WAS DURING THE
TIME OF MCCARTHYISM. ANTI
COMMUNISM. AND THE BLACKLISTING
WHEN IN FACT SO MANY LGBTQ MEN
AND WOMEN WERE PUT ON THOSE
LISTS BECAUSE THEY WERE DEEMED
A SECURITY RISK BY THIS COUNTRY.
THAT WAS THEN. AND I KNOW THAT
SOME PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ANTI LGBTQ
DISCRIMINATION DOESN'T EXIST
THEY MIGHT THINK WE CAN'T STOP
TALKING ABOUT OUR HISTORY OF
MAKING LGBTQ FOLKS SECOND CLASS
CITIZENS NOW WE CAN STOP HAVING
OUR PARADES THAT WE CAN STOP
WAVING OUR FLAGS. BUT I WOULD
REMIND THOSE FOLKS THAT IT WAS
ONLY IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT.
WHEN VOTERS CONSIDERED PASSING
THE BRIGGS INITIATIVE WHICH
WOULD HAVE BANNED GAY TEACHERS
FROM TEACHING IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. IT WAS THAT NINETEEN
EIGHTIES WHEN AIDS RAVAGED
COMMUNITIES OF GAY BLACK MEN
AND OUR GOVERNMENT DIDN'T EVEN
TRACK THE NUMBER OF DEATHS.
INSTEAD THEY CALLED IT THE GAME
PLAY AND SINCE BLACK MEN WERE
THE ONES DYING IT WASN'T
SOMETHING THAT THEY NEEDED TO
WORRY ABOUT. IT WAS ONLY IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT WHEN
YOUNG STUDENT MATTHEW SHEPARD.
WAS TORTURED AND BEATEN AND
LEFT TO DIE. AND IT WAS AS
RECENT AS TWENTY THIRTEEN TO
FOUR YEARS TOO LATE WHEN
CALIFORNIANS FINALLY REALIZE
THAT EVERYONE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
MARRY THE PERSON THEY LOVE AND
WANT TO SPEND THEIR LIVES WITH.
WE HAVE MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS
SINCE THEN BUT THERE IS STILL
WORK AHEAD IN TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE HAVE SEEN
AN UPTICK IN HOMICIDES OF OUR
BLACK GAY AND LESBIAN TRANS
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. AND OUR
TRANS BLACK COMMUNITY IS THREE
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE
VIOLENCE FROM POLICE. SO TODAY
WE NEED TO GET IT TOGETHER. AND
WE NEED TO REAFFIRM OUR
COMMITMENT. TO OUR LGBTQ
BROTHERS AND SISTERS WHO ARE
FAMILY MEMBERS AND OUR FRIENDS.
AND WE NEED TO REAFFIRM OUR
COMMITMENT TO TREATING ALL
PEOPLE IN THIS STATE WITH
RESPECT AND DIGNITY REGARDLESS
OF WHO THEY LOVE. I AM
FORTUNATE THAT THIS MONTH I
WILL BE CELEBRATING THEIR
SEVENTH WEDDING ANNIVERSARY OF
MY AUNT CAROL LEE TO HER WIFE
KELLY. AND I AM GLAD BUT SHE
WAS ABLE TO MARRY THE PERSON
THAT SHE LOVES. WITH DIGNITY
AND RESPECT AND SAFETY FROM
VIOLENCE BUT NOT ALL OF US HAVE
THAT. SO I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BAKER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND THANK YOU TO THE
SENATOR FOR STOCKED IN THE PRO
TEM THE SENATORS FROM SANTA
CRUZ AND SAN FRANCISCO FOR YOUR
LONG LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
IN YOUR CAREERS IN PUBLIC
SERVICE MAKING LIFE BETTER FOR
THE NEXT GENERATION THE FACT
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE TODAY FEEL
MORE COMFORTABLE COMING OUT AS
A TRIBUTE TO YOUR WORK. I STAND
IN SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION
THIS MONTH WE HONOR THE
FEARLESS THE TRAILBLAZERS. THE
EXTRAORDINARY AND ALSO THE
EVERYDAY HEROES AT THE TOP OF
THE LG. G. FIVE G. L. G. B. T.
Q. PLUS A MOVEMENT. IN THEIR
FIGHT FOR EQUAL RIGHTS. AND IN
MAKING- AGAIN IF POSSIBLE AND
COMFORTABLE FOR ALL KIDS ALL
CHILDREN OF PEOPLE TODAY TO
COME OUT YOU MAKE US BETTER
WHERE ALSO THE VITAL IMPORTANCE
OF RECOGNIZING AND CELEBRATING
OUR TRUE SELVES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR LEVEL.
LATER SORRY THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I TOO WANT TO THANK THE
CENTER FROM SOCKS AND THE LGBTQ
CAUCUS FOR BRINGING SR THIRTY
NINE FORWARD I ALWAYS LIKE TO
GET UP AND TALK ABOUT A
PARENT'S PERSPECTIVE AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM OAKLAND DID THE
SAME THING AND I LIKE TO DO
THAT BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE A
GAY CHILD WHETHER YOU WANT TO
BE PULLED INTO IT OR NOT YOU
SEE THE WAY A LOT OF FAMILIES
TREAT THEIR CHILDREN WHEN THEY
COME OUT TO THEM IT WAS REALLY
HEARTBREAKING TO ME AS A MOM OF
A DAUGHTER WHO IS GAY. TO SEE
SOME OF HER FRIENDS WHO ARE GAY
AND HOW THEY WERE TREATED THE
ONE THAT STRUCK ME THE MOST WAS
A BRILLIANT YOUNG MAN IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND- WHEN HE'S HE SPOKE
THREE LANGUAGES IN HIGH SCHOOL
AND WHEN HE CAME OUT TO HIS
PARENTS THEY KICKED HIM OUT OF
THE HOUSE AND THEY DIDN'T
WELCOMING BACK INTO THEIR HOME
FOR SEVERAL YEARS SO AT THAT
TIME OUR DAUGHTERS WERE IN HIGH
SCHOOL. THANKS INKLING THAT
MAYBE- MAYBE JESSE WAS GAY AND
SOMEONE TO MAKE SURE SHE FELT
REALLY WELCOME AND KNEW THAT
SHE COULD TELL HER PARENTS
ANYTHING AND THAT WE WOULD
ALWAYS LOVE HER SO SIMILAR TO
MY COLLEAGUE FROM OAKLAND I
THOUGHT I WOULD DO SOMETHING
THAT WOULD JUST REALLY MAKE HER
FEEL WELCOME WE ALWAYS TALKED
ABOUT IN OUR HOUSE YOU COULD
DISAGREE WE CAN ARGUE ABOUT
THINGS MY HUSBAND I WANTED TO
HEAR THEIR OPINIONS SO WE'RE
HAVING ONE OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS I SAID YOU KNOW.
THE ONLY THING THAT WILL GET
YOU KICKED OUT OF THE LABOR
FAMILY IS IF YOU HURT SMALL
ANIMALS ARE YOU REGISTERED
REPUBLICAN. SO LATE. WHEN OUR
DAUGHTER CAME OUT TO US I SAID
TO HER I SAID JESSE DID MY
LITTLE TALK HELP YOU. AND SHE
SAID. NO MOTHER SHE GOES I
ALWAYS KNEW I COULD TELL YOU IN
DOUBT. SO THAT MADE ME FEEL
REALLY GOOD. BUT I JUST THINK
THAT. PARENTS WHO HAVE GAY
CHILDREN. SHOULD ALWAYS
REMEMBER THE DAY THEY COME OUT
TO YOU. THEY'RE THE EXACT SAME
PERSON. THEY WERE THE DAY
BEFORE. LOVE IS LOVE MY
DAUGHTER IS HAPPILY MARRIED TO
HER WIFE. THEY HAVE A LITTLE
BOY OUR GRANDSON NICO. AND
THERE'S NOTHING BETTER THAN
SEEING YOUR CHILDREN. GAY OR
STRAIGHT. THRIVE IN LIFE THANK
YOU AND I SUPPORT SR THIRTY
NINE. THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE
TODAY I ALSO WRITE A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SR THIRTY NINE.
AND I WANT TO THANK GOD MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CHINO AND
DISCUSSING YOU KNOW THE PARENT
PERSPECTIVE AND I WILL SHARE A
LITTLE BIT OF MY PERSPECTIVE AS
A TEACHER. JUST EXPERIENCING
SOME STUDENTS STRUGGLING WITH
INTERNAL STRUGGLES AND HOW TO
CONVEY. THEIR STORY TO THEIR
OWN PARENTS SANDY AND IT IS.
EXACTLY HOW THE GREAT CENTER
FROM MARTINO STATED. THE
CHILDREN DON'T CHANGE THE
PEOPLE DON'T CHANGE THEIR THE
SAME EXACT PERSON THAT YOU
LOVED. BEFORE THEY CAME OUT TO
YOU. BUT I DO WANT TO JUST
RECOGNIZE ALL THE PROGRESS
WE'VE MADE AS A SOCIETY AND
ALSO. THANK ALL THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT OUR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS IN THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY HAVE MADE AND
THERE'VE BEEN MANY. AND A LOT
OF THE TIMES THEY'RE OVERLOOKED
OR NOT HIGHLIGHTED IN IN THIS.
PRIDE MONTH I THINK IT'S JUST
APPROPRIATE THAT WE DO I DON'T
WANT TO REITERATE WHAT APPLIES
THE GREAT CENTER FROM LOS
ANGELES STATED YOU KNOW GOING
BACK TO OUR INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER WE GOT A LOT ON TO
OUR PRO TEM AND SO MANY OTHERS.
BUT I JUST WANT TO REMIND US
THAT RESPECT SHOULD ALWAYS BE
PRESENT TOLERANCE SHOULD ALWAYS
BE PRESENT. AND SOLIDARITY WITH
THESE COMMUNITIES SHOULD ALWAYS
BE PRESENT NO MATTER WHAT THE
MONDAY SO I HOPE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD. WITH
LOVE RESPECT AND DIGNITY AND
JUST ALWAYS REMEMBER THAT THE
NEXT GENERATION. IS WATCHING
CLOSELY AND WHAT WE DO MATTERS
WHAT WE SAY MATTERS AND OUR
ACTIONS MATTER AND TO ALL THOSE
WATCHING WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY KNOW. THAT WE STAND
IN SOLIDARITY WITH OUR LGBTQ.
BROTHERS AND SISTERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. WELL I WANNA THANK MY
COLLEAGUES WERE VERY HEARTFELT
AND READ ROBUST DISCUSSION ON A
VERY IMPORTANT MATTER SENATOR
GRAHAM WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOUVERY MUCH I'M GONNA
THINK THAT MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR KIND AND SUPPORTIVE. BAD
COMMENTS AS SOMEONE WHO HAS NOW
BEEN WITH MY WIFE FOR YEARS.
ALTHOUGH THE STATE HAS ONLY
ACKNOWLEDGED THE LAST SEVEN OF
THE YEARS WE'VE SPENT TOGETHER
AND IN THE EARLY DAYS WE
COULDN'T HAVE DREAMED OF
WALKING DOWN THE STREET HOLDING
HANDS WITHOUT FEAR OF
HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT AND THAT
WE CAN NOW HOLD OUR OUR LITTLE
GIRL'S HAND BETWEEN US AS WE
WALK DOWN THE STREET SHOWS THE
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE. BUT WE
STILL KNOW THAT THERE'S SO MUCH
MORE TO GO ON THIS ROAD SO- MAY
WE ALL BE REMINDED THAT THERE
IS A RAINBOW ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THAT STORM AND TO KEEP ON
STRIVING TOWARDS THAT WHERE
THERE IS FINALLY AT PEACE LOVE
AND INCLUSION FOR ALL OF US. AS
I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE CLERK TO
READ THE NAMES OF THE TWELVE L.
G. B. T. Q. PLUS PRIDE MEMBERS
HONOREES. FOR TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU HEARING
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO SR
THIRTY NINE. ALAN ARCHULETA
FIVE ATKINS FIVE BATES. I
BACKER HI FORGES. BRADFORD I
COME BY OTHER HI COURTESY HI
DALLY. DODD HI TORONTO HI ADNAN
I. GLAZER FIVE DOLLARS HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI
HER TADO I JONES. KAREN WALKER
I LAYERED HI LLEVA BY THE MON I
REQUIRE. MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. BUT SHOW A
VOGUE I PAN I FORTUNE TINO. I.
ROSS HI RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
I AM BERG ALL RIGHT HI WACO SKI
I WINNER I WILL LOOK. SENATOR
ADMIN MOVES A CALL NOW MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE NAMES
OF OUR HONOREES. ROBERT GENTRY
HE HIM ROBERT GENTRY IS A
DEVOTED PUBLIC SERVANT WHO
BECAME THE FIRST OPENLY GAY
MAYOR IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
CITY OF LAGUNA BEACH BEFORE AND
AFTER HIS THREE CONSECUTIVE
TERMS AS MAYOR GENTRY HAS
WORKED TIRELESSLY TIRELESSLY TO
INCREASE EQUALITY AND ADDRESS
ISSUES IMPACTING THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY. AUTOMATICS HE HIM
CONNOR MADDOX IS A TRANSGENDER
ACTIVIST AND RECIPIENT OF THE
HARVEY MILK CIVIL RIGHTS AWARD
HE HAS WORKED FOR NUMEROUS
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROMOTE CIVIL
RIGHTS AND EQUALITYINCLUDING
THE SAN DIEGO LGBT Q. CENTER
AND THE SAN DIEGO TRANS
MASCULINE DISCUSSION GROUP.
DENNIS SONNY HE HAM TENNIS
SONNY IS A MARINE CORPS VETERAN
WHOSE WORK WITH CALIFORNIA'S
MANUFACTURING NETWORK HAS LED
TO NUMEROUS TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCEMENTS IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE. HE HAS DEDICATED MUCH
OF HIS CAREER TO ADVANCING
DIVERSITY AND CURRENTLY SERVES
ON THE BOARDS OF THE SCIENCE
AND TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION
PARTNERSHIP FOUNDATION AND THE
GARNER HOLDS FOUNDATION. LLOYD
HOMES HE HIM. DR LLOYD HOMES
IT'S A LIFE LONG EDUCATOR AND
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE WHO
CURRENTLY SERVES AS A PRESIDENT
A DANCER COLLEGE IN CUPERTINO.
HE IS THE FIRST OPENLY GAY
BLACK MAN TO HOLD THIS TITLE
AND HE HAS DEDICATED HIS CAREER
TO INCREASING STUDENT SUCCESS
AND RETENTION. TRUE LLOYD HE
HIM HIS. THROUGH LOYD'S WORK.
IN THE TECH AND LEGAL INDUSTRY
HAS MADE HIM ONE OF THE MOST
INFLUENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS
CONSULTANTS IN SILICON VALLEY.
HE IS THE BOARD PRESIDENT OF
BAY MAC THE OLDEST NONPARTISAN
LGBTQ PLUS POLITICAL ACTION
COMMITTEE IN CALIFORNIA. KERRY
MCCOY HE HAM. GARY MCCOY IS THE
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC AFFAIRS FOR
HEALTH RIGHT THREE SIXTY WHICH
FOCUSES ON MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT HE
HAS DEDICATED HIS CAREER TO
PUBLIC SERVICE AND HE HAS
WORKED IN THE OFFICE OF HOUSE
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI IN
ADDITION TO SERVING AS CO
PRESIDENT OF THE ALICE B.
TOKLAS LGBT Q. DEMOCRATIC CLUB.
KIM TRAN SHE HER. KIM TRAN IS A
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZER RESEARCHER
AND WRITER WHOSE WORK HAS
SPARKED SOCIAL CHANGE THROUGH A
UNIQUE APPROACH TO COMBATING
INJUSTICE AND OPPRESSION.
PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO
ASIAN AMERICAN SOLIDARITY AND
THE BLACK LIVES MATTER MOVEMENT.
LANGLAND HOW HE HIM. LANGLAND
TAU HAS AN EX EXTENSIVE
BACKGROUND IN EDUCATION AND
CURRENTLY SERVES AS THE
DIRECTOR OF EXTERNAL RELATIONS
FOR THE EDUCATION TRUST WEST.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN HE BECAME THE
FIRST OPENLY GAY MAN ELECTED TO
PUBLIC OFFICE IN STOCKTON. LUIS
ALFARO HE HAM. LUIS ALFARO IS A
LOS ANGELES BASED AUTHOR POET
AND PERFORMER WHOSE WORK HAS
WON NUMEROUS AWARDS INCLUDING A
MACARTHUR FELLOWSHIP. HE IS
CURRENTLY AN ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. ROBERTA
ACHTENBERG SHE HER REDACTING
BERG HAS SERVED IN MANY ROLES
DURING HER EXTENSIVE GOVERNMENT
AND LEGAL CAREER INCLUDING THE
POSITION OF FAIR HOUSING
ASSISTANT SECRETARY IN NINETEEN
NINETY THREE SHE MADE HISTORY
AS THE FIRST OPENLY LGBT Q.
PLUS PERSON TO BE
PRESIDENTIALLY NOMINATED AND
CONFIRMED BY THE U. S. SENATE.
POSTHUMOUS HONOREES GEORGE
MURPHY HE HIM GEORGE MURPHY WAS
AN ICON IN SAN DIEGO'S LGBTQ
PLUS COMMUNITY AND A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF THE SAN DIEGO LGBTQ
COMMUNITY CENTER HE WORKED AS
AN ACADEMIC COUNSELOR AT
GROSSMONT COLLEGE AND WAS
HEAVILY INVOLVED IN HIS CHURCH.
LARRY BAZA HE HIM WARY BECAUSE
IT WAS A DEDICATED LGBTQ PLUS
ACTIVIST WHO'S WHO DEVOTED HIS
LIFE TO ADVANCING CIVIL AND
WORKER RIGHTS HE PASSED AWAY IN
FEBRUARY BUT HIS LEGACY
CONTINUES TO REVERBERATE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY IN SAN
DIEGO WHERE HE TIRELESSLY I'VE
ADVOCATED FOR THE ARTS AND
GREATER ACCESS TO EDUCATION.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT LET'S.
GIVE A SENATE CONGRATULATIONS
TO THOSE AMAZING HONOREES.
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE TEAM READ. MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEAN READ
REPORTS FROM COMMITTEES WILL BE
DOING READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. OTHER MOTIONS RATHER
RESOLUTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SENATE JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF
JUNE FOURTEENTH AND SEVENTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL BE WILL
BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. MEMBERS RESERVE
ANY OTHER THING UNDER MOTIONS
IMAGE RESOLUTIONS. IN G. NINE
NOW MOVING ON TO CONSIDERATION
OF A DAILY FILE WE HAVE SECOND
READING FILE MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS THREE EIGHTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN TWELVE ELEVEN EIGHTY
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN TWENTY SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTY TWO SIX THIRTY FOUR.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE OH TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS. THIRTEEN OH FOUR
WITH AMENDMENTS AND ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO FORTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU NOW
MOVING ON TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS WE HAVE FILE ITEM
NINETEEN THAT'S WHY SENATOR
NELSON ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
THAT ITEM I SEE THAT HE IS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY NINE BY
SENATOR NLSON AN ACT RELATING
TO COUNTRY COUNTY ROADS AND
DECLARING THEIR JUST THEIR
URGENCY VERA TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY SENATOR NELSON THIS
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE THIS BILL PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE IN THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS THIS ALLOWS THE
COUNTIES OF COLUSA. AND GLENN
COUNTY. TO BE ABLE TO. ALLOW
THE DIRECTOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC WORKS FOR THE DIRECTOR
THERE OF- TO- ALLOW THE COUNTY
ROAD COMMISSION TO COMBINE THAT
WITH THE WITH THE COUNTY ROAD
COMMISSION AND RATHER YOU HAVE
IT TWO INDIVIDUALS A
COMMISSIONER. IF YOU WILL ENTER
DIRECTOR THIS WILL COMBINE
THOSE IN THE KING THE SMALL
COUNTIES. AND THAT THAT'S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN VERY MUCH I
THINK THERE'S ONLY ONE OTHER
SIMILAR- SITUATION WHERE
COUNTIES HAVE COMBINED THE
OFFICE. BUT IT MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE FOR THOSE SMALL COUNTIES.
NUMBER ONE IT IS VERY DIFFICULT
TO OBTAIN PEOPLE TO DO THOSE
JOBS. THOSE COUNTIES CANNOT
AFFORD TO PAY COMPETITIVE
SALARIES SO IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT SITUATION. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS SIMPLY
ADDED TO. THE COUNTY OF
POLLUTION WHICH WAS THE
ORIGINAL AND THE BAIL. BOND
COUNTY DECIDED THEY'D LIKE TO
JOIN AND WE'VE ASKED THEM TO DO
THAT AND THEY HAVE AND THAT
SUPPORT GROUP FOR THE PURPOSE
OF THE AMENDMENT AND IF YOU
WOULD BE SO KIND WOULD
APPRECIATE AND. I VOTE ON THE
AMENDED BILL. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSS ON S. B.
SEVENTY NINE. HERE IN NC NINE
MINUTES SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA I
ACTIONS I BATES I BECKER. I
PORCHES FIVE BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM HI CORTESE HI DALLY. I DON
I- ALSO BY ADMIN. I GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HI GROSS. HI HERZBERG
HI WEST SO. I HER TADO HI JONES
I CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA
I THE MON I REQUIRE. MELINDA'S
FIVE MEN I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN I
WOULD SHOW UP BOTH I PAN HI
FORTUNE TINO HI ROB HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER. STERN I AMBERG HI
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER I WOKE.
MMHM SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE OB
TO MEMBERS. ALAN PAUL MCGUIRE.
SKINNER WELK. SENATOR MOVES A
CALL NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR LAVE US SHE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY BY
SENATOR LEYVA RELATIVE TO THE
FORTY NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF
TITLE NINE SOONER OR LATER
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT SENATE RESOLUTION
FORTY WHICH COMMENT
COMMEMORATES THE FORTY NINTH
ANNIVERSARY OF TITLE NINE ON
WEDNESDAY JUNE TWENTY THIRD
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TITLE NINE
OF THE EDUCATION AMENDMENTS OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO IS A
FEDERAL LAW THAT SPECIFICALLY
STATES. NO PERSON IN THE UNITED
STATES SHELL ON THE BASIS OF
SEX BE EXCLUDED FROM
PARTICIPATION IN BE DENIED THE
BENEFITS OF OR BE SUBJECTED TO
DISCRIMINATION UNDER ANY
EDUCATION PROGRAM OR ACTIVITY
RECEIVING FEDERAL FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE. AS CHAIR OF THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
INTERMARRIAGES OF LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS AS A MOTHER OF
TWO DAUGHTERS WHO WERE STUDENT
ATHLETES TITLE NINE IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO ME AND
SO MANY OTHERS. PRIOR TO THE
ENACTMENT OF TITLE NINE MANY
WOMEN AND GIRLS FACE
DISCRIMINATION UNLIMITED
OPPORTUNITIES IN ATHLETICS
ACADEMICS AND EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES. TITLE NINE WHICH
GOVERNS EDUCATIONAL EQUITY
GENERALLY IS WIDELY KNOWN FOR
ENSURING EQUAL ACCESS TO WOMEN
AND GIRLS ATHLETES AS OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN GIRLS
PARTICIPATION IN HIGH SCHOOL
ATHLETICS ATHLETICS. HAS
INCREASED MORE THAN A 1000%
SINCE TITLE NINE WAS ENACTED A
1000% THAT IS AMAZING.
DISCRIMINATION ON THE BASIS OF
SEX CAN ALSO INCLUDE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OR SEXUAL VIOLENCE
INCLUDING RAPE SEXUAL ASSAULT
SEXUAL BATTERY AND SEXUAL
COERCION. TEL NINE HAS BEEN
USED AS A BASIS IN A NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS ALLEGING SEXUAL
VIOLENCE ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES AS
SEXUAL VIOLENCE INTERFERES WITH
A STUDENT'S RIGHT TO RECEIVE
EDUCATION FREE FROM
DISCRIMINATION. WHAT MANY
PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT TITLE NINE
ONLY HELPS WOMEN AND GIRLS THAT
HAVE ACTUALLY IS INCLUSIVE OF
ALL PEOPLE IT PROTECTS EVERYONE
FROM SEX BASED DISCRIMINATION
REGARDLESS OF REAL OR PERCEIVED
SEX GENDER IDENTITY OR GENDER
EXPRESSION WELL TITLE NINE HAS.
INCREASED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
WOMEN GIRLS AND MANY OTHER
AMERICANS WE STILL HAVE A VERY
LONG WAY TO GO. COMMEMORATING
THIS ANNIVERSARY IS IMPORTANT
REMINDERS ALL OF THE CONTINUED
WORK THAT WE MUST DO TOGETHER.
TO REACH THE GOALS OF TITLE
NINE OF INCREASED EQUITY
EQUALITY AND FAIR TREATMENT OF
ALL STUDENTS MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE DR VAN.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- CENTERS
I TO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SR FORTY IS- CHAIR OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LETS THE CLOCK
AND SO I THINK MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM CHINO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD RECOGNIZING FORTY NINTH
ANNIVERSARY OF TITLE NINE.
TITLE NINE HAS BEEN
FOUNDATIONAL IN COMBAT ENGINE
GENDER DISCRIMINATION EDUCATION
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO. AS
MENTIONED IS NOTED THAT- WOMEN
AND GIRLS DISSIPATION IN HIGH
SCHOOL COLLEGIATE ATHLETICS HAS
INCREASED EXPONENTIALLY. IN
RECOGNIZING THE MOMENTOUS
IMPACT OF TITLE NINE WE ALSO
NEED TO HONOR FORMER
CONGRESSWOMAN PAT ET MINK OF
HAWAII THE FIRST WOMAN OF COLOR
AND ASIAN AMERICAN ELECTED TO
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES TO
CALL OFF THEIR TITLE NINE. FOR
THE EIGHT ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY THIS
TALISMAN TITLE NINE HAS
PROVIDED AN AVENUE FOR MANY.
AAPI WOMEN TO GAIN ACCESS. TO
NEW OPPORTUNITIES UNFORTUNATELY
API WOMEN ARE STILL VULNERABLE
TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION DUE TO RACIST
STEREOTYPES. THIS RESOLUTION AS
A REMINDER OF HOW FAR WE HAVE
COME IN MAKING NECESSARY
ACTIONS PROVIDE A BETTER FUTURE
FOR EVERY AMERICAN AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY FOR THE VULNERABLE
UNDER REPRESENT OFTEN HEARD. IS
ALSO CALLED TO ACTION TO
CONTINUALLY CHANGE THE SYSTEM
THUS THE STARKLY ENABLED GENDER
IMBALANCES IS OUR HOPE THAT
RAISING AWARENESS IS
CELEBRATING TITLE NINE WILL
INSPIRE FUTURE PROGRESS IN
ACHIEVING THIS GOAL OF GENDER
EQUALITY. HI SPEC WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR S. R. FORTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING C. NINE. CENTER LEVEL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE
THANK YOU MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON SR FORTY. ALAN
ARCHULETA R. I. ATKINS I BASE.
BACKER FIVE PORGES I BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM I COURTESY HI
DALLY. I DON HI TORONTO I
EXAMINED I GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH. HI
HERZ BERG. HI WITH SO I HER
TADO. HI JONES I CAM AUGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA. HI LYNN MON
HI MCGUIRE. MELINDA'S. MAN FIVE
NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN. I- CHOKE I
CAN I FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH I
REVIEW. HI SKINNER. STERN HI
I'M BURKE I WHAT CASSIE I
WINNER. I WILL I. ZURCHER
PLEASE CALL UP TO MEMBERS. ALAN
FACE I. MCGUIRE MELINDA'S.
SKINNER. SENATOR LABOR MOVES A
CALL NOW MOVING ON TO A SIMPLY
THIRD READING FILE ITEM THIRTY
SIX BY SIX SENATOR WIENER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR THIRTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARRICADE HAND
AN ACT RELATING TO CERTIFICATES
OF DEATH. SOONER WINNER FOR
GEORGE THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT A
SUMMARY BILL FOR THIRTY NINE ON
BEHALF OF THE SUMMER MEMBER
BAUER K. HINES- WHICH WILL
ALLOW NON BINARY INDIVIDUALS TO
BE IDENTIFIED AS SUCH ON THEIR
DEATH CERTIFICATES- LANGUAGE
MATTERS COLLEAGUES AND STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT WHEN NON BINARY
USE FEEL THEIR PRONOUNS AND
THEIR EXISTENCE ARE BEING
RESPECTED AND ACKNOWLEDGED. BY
THEIR HEALTH IS LIKELY TO
ATTEMPT SUICIDE IN MANY OTHER
STATES WERE SAYING OF STARVING
INCREASING LEGISLATION
TARGETING THE BASIC RIGHTS OF
TRANS AND NON BINARY PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY YOUTH. RELATING TO
VITAL HEALTH CARE AND
RECOGNITION I'M PROUD TO BE
PART OF A MOVEMENT IN A
LEGISLATURE THAT HAS MADE
CALIFORNIA LEADER IN PROTECTING
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY- AND OUR
RIGHTS TO LIVE. OUR OUR TRUE
SELVES IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
COLORS ARE PRO TEM GREATLY
EXPANDED THE LEGAL RECOGNITION
OF NON BINARY IDENTITIES BY
PASSING LEGISLATION TO INCLUDE
NON BINARY GENDER GENDER.
MARKERS ON BIRTH CERTIFICATES
AND OTHER LEGAL DOCUMENTS LIKE
DRIVER'S LICENSES- THE BILL
BEFORE US TODAY BUILDS ON I
COULD WORK- AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN IPO. THANK YOU IN
FURTHER. OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
IN NINETEEN NINETY MINUTE SIR
TERRY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX EIGHTY
FOUR THIRTY NINE. ALAN
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I BASICS.
BACKER I PORCHES. BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM I CORTESE I DALLY
NO DOG. HI THERE ALSO I EXAMINE.
GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG I WISH SO. I HER
TADO I JONES. CAMCORDER I
LAYERED I LLEVA. MY MOM FIVE
MCGUIRE. MELINDA'S NO MAN HI
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NOPE A SHOW
ABOUT OAK. HI TAM HI FOURTEEN
TO NO. I BROUGHT. HI RUBIO I
SKINNER. STERN HI I'M BURKE ALL
RIGHT HI WHAT CASKEY I WINNER
HI WELL NOW. ZURCHER PLEASE
CALL UP TO MEMBERS. ALAN. FAITH
NO. PORGES ADMIN. JONES LLEVA.
MCGUIRE SKINNER. CENTER WINNER
MOVED TO CALL. MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ONTO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE
THERE ANY COMEDIAN
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO BE MADE AT
THIS TIME. SENATOR CORTEZ YOU.
YES SIR- LABOR COMMITTEE WILL
MEET- IMMEDIATELY AFTER A
SESSION CONCLUDES TODAY AND I
BELIEVE WE'RE IN FOR TWO OR
THREE. SENATE LABOR WILL MEET
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
IMMEDIATELY AFTER SESSION.
SENATOR WAY SO. SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY TO LOSING
COMMUNICATIONS WILL MEET HERE
IN THE SENATE CHANGE CHAMBER
MEMBER GERMAN OBSESSION. SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS WILL MEET
HERE IN THE SENATE CHAMBER WILL
TO SUPPORT OUR STAFF ENOUGH
TIME TO CLEAN THE- CHAMBER UP
SO. MAYBE WE'LL SAY THREE
THIRTY. ALL RIGHT CITY CENTER
WHY KASKI FOR PURPOSE. NO OKAY.
SENATOR CALM WATER. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I HAVE A BRIEF
AMOUNT NELSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS WE WANT TO INVITE YOU TO
OUR JUNETEENTH BLACK GENEALOGY
HISTORY EVENT IT WILL BE
HAPPENING TOMORROW WHICH IS
TUESDAY FROM FOUR TO SIX THIRTY
PM AT THE CALIFORNIA MUSEUM AND
EVERYONE IS WELCOME IT WILL BE
CELEBRATE TORY AND
INFORMATIONAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO TOMORROW AT THE
CALIFORNIA LIBRARY MUSEUM. FROM
FOUR TO SIX THIRTY BLACK
HISTORY MONTH EVENT MEAN- BLACK
CAUCUS EVENT INSURANCE SUPPORT
CELEBRATION OF JUNETEENTH. MALE
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
RETURNING TO RID- MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS NOW IS THE TIME FOR
OUR JOURNEY AND MEMORIES SIR
WHY BECAUSE HE- THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO JUROR IN
THE MEMORY OF MY FRIEND- V. N.
LARSON WHO IS A LONGTIME
EDUCATOR OF THIS THE TEN SENATE
DISTRICT WHO PASSED AWAY
EARLIER THIS MONTH FROM CANCER.
HE RECEIVED HER MASTER'S DEGREE
IN EDUCATION FROM CATHOLIC
UNIVERSITY. ENVELOP POTTERY CEO
IN HER NATIVE CHILE HE ALSO
THEN EARNED A MASTER'S DEGREE
FROM SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY
AND CREDENTIALS AND SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATION SCHOOL
COUNSELING AND COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO AND UC
BERKELEY. REVIEW AND TAUGHT IN
OAKLAND SCHOOLS AND AT CAL
STATE HAYWARD WHICH IS NOW CAL
STATE EAST BAY EAST BAY BEFORE
A LONG CAREER IN THE NEWARK
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT SHE
BECAME VICE PRINCIPAL AT NEWARK
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND WAS A
COUNSELOR AT THE NEWARK
MEMORIAL HIGH SCHOOL. IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN MS LARSON
BECAME A MEMBER OF THE ALONI
COLLEGE BOARD OF TRUSTEES WHERE
SHE CONTINUED HER WORK IN
EDUCATION FOR ANOTHER TEN
YEARS. SHE ALSO FOUNDED.
HOWEVER ZONDO A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION TO PROMOTE THE
ADVANCEMENT AND EMPOWERMENT OF
LATINO YOUTH THROUGH EDUCATION
LEADERSHIP AND NETWORK
OPPORTUNITIES LEAVING LARSON
WAS A KIND AND GENEROUS WOMAN
WHO GAVE SO MUCH BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY. EDUCATION WAS HER
PASSION AND SHE DEDICATED HER
LIFE. TO INSPIRING TO HER
STUDENTS AND OPENING DOORS OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF THEM SHE
HAD ALWAYS HAD A SMILE ON HER
FACE AND IT WAS. A WARM AND
FRIENDLY TO THE FOLKS WHENEVER
I SAW HER SHE WILL BE MISSED BY
ALL OF US WHO KNEW HER AND
ASKED THAT WE RETURN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU SENATOR WHY COSTLY
PLEASE BRING THAT NAME FOR IT
SO IT CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED NOW MOVING ON TO
SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
JUNE IN MEMORY OF KERRY TO
MINGUS A LONGTIME FIREFIGHTER
AND RESIDENT MY CITY OF
FULLERTON. WHO PASSED AWAY ON
MAY FIFTH AT THE AGE OF SIXTY
ONE AFTER A LONG AND VALIANT
BATTLE WITH BRAIN CANCER. MR
DIMMING IS PROVIDED TWENTY NINE
YEARS OF DEDICATED SERVICE TO
THE CITY OF ORIGIN AS A MEMBER
OF FLORENCE FIRE DEPARTMENT
REACHING THE RANK. OF DIVISION
CHIEF OF OPERATIONS IN TWENTY
TEN. AFTER RETIRING FROM THE
FIRE DEPARTMENT TWENTY TWELVE
MISTER TO MAKE A STAND SERVICE
FIRE CHIEF FOR THE CITY OF LAVA
HEIGHTS. FOR THOSE WHO WORK
ALONGSIDE MR DOMINGUEZ HIS
QUIET LEADERSHIP AND CALMING
DEMEANOR SET HIM APART HE
UNFAILINGLY TOOK THE TIME TO
ASK. HOW EACH OF HIS
FIREFIGHTERS WAS DOING. HE WAS
ABOVE ALL A LEADER WHO CARED
ABOUT THE PEOPLE WITH WHOM WE
SERVE THAT IS WHAT MAKE YOUR
DEMAND IS. SUCH A BELOVED
FIGURE IN THE FIREFIGHTING
COMMUNITY IN FULLERTON. AND
BEYOND MR DOMINGUEZ'S
CONTRIBUTIONS TO FIREFIGHTING
EXTENDED BEYOND THE FIRE HOUSE
AND INTO THE CLASSROOM. AFTER
ONLY FORTY FOUR YEARS AS A
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTER. HE
BEGAN SERVING AS AN INSTRUCTOR
AT THE FIRE ACADEMY AT SANTA
ANA COMMUNITY COLLEGE. AND
REMAIN AN INTEGRAL PART OF THAT
INSTITUTION FOR THIRTY FOUR
YEARS. DURING HIS LAST NINE
YEARS BUT THE COLLEGE SHE
PROUDLY SERVED AS THE FIRE
ACADEMY'S DIRECTOR. THOUSANDS
OF FIREFIGHTERS WHO HAVE
TRAINED AT SANTA ANA. AND WHO
HAVE GONE ON TO SERVE IN ORANGE
COUNTY BEYOND- GERRY DOMINGUEZ
A GREAT DAD. ORANGE COUNTY AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS A
WHOLE ARE EQUALLY FORTUNATE TO
HAVE HAD THE BENEFIT. OF CHIEF
DOMINGUEZ'S LEADERSHIP.
DEDICATION AND MENTORSHIP KERRY
DOMINGUEZ LEAVES BEHIND HIS
WIFE SUSIE. HIS SISTER ARLENE
HIS DAUGHTERS AMY AND
CHRISTINA. AND HER SON GARY HE
ALSO LEAVES BEHIND HIS BROTHERS
AND SISTERS AT THE FULLERTON
FIRE DEPARTMENT A FAMILY THAT
PROVIDED HIM. UNCONDITIONAL
LOVE AND SUPPORT THROUGH HIS
LONG AND ACCOMPLISHED
PROFESSIONAL LIFE HE WILL BE
DEARLY MISSED. AND I ASK. THAT
WE ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY
TODAY. THANK YOU FOR STAYING
THE SENATE CONDONE. TO MISS
DOMINGUEZ AND WE ARE SET. NAME
FOR TWO WE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. MEMBERS WERE
GONNA PAUSE FOR A MINUTE.
WE
WERE JUST WAITING FOR FEW
MEMBERS TO RETURN BACK TO FLOOR
THEY'RE MAKING BILL
PRESENTATIONS OVER AN ASSEMBLY
SO AS SOON AS THEY THERE ARE
BACK FROM THEIR WILL LOOK THE
CALLS.
SENATOR SKINNER ARE YOU
PREPARED TO DO YOUR RETURN A
MEMBER AT THIS TIME. YES I AM
ONE MOMENT. OKAY THANK YOU- MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. TODAY I'M
STANDING AND ASKING US TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF THE
BOUNDARY PUSHING COMEDIAN
RICHARD PRYOR'S LONG TIME
WRITING PARTNER AND MY
CONSTITUENT PAUL MOONEY WHO
DIED MAY NINETEENTH AT HIS HOME
IN OAKLAND MOONEY WAS KNOWN FOR
HIS BOLD AND INCISIVE
COMMENTARY ON RACISM IN
AMERICAN LIFE AND WAS ALSO A
REAL HIGHLY RESPECTED STAND UP
COMEDIAN. HE WROTE FOR AN
APPEARED REGULARLY ON DAVE
CHAPELLE CHAPELLE SHOW AND ONE
OF HIS BEST KNOWN BITS ON THAT
SHOW WAS ASKED A BLACK DUDE IN
WHICH WHITE PEOPLE WOULD ASK
DUMB QUESTIONS AND MOONEY WOULD
RESPOND WITH HILARIOUS AND
UNAPOLOGETICALLY DEFIANT
ANSWERS IN ONE EPISODE A PERSON
ASKED CAN BLACK MEN JUMP REALLY
HIGH. ALL RIGHT YES BLACK
PEOPLE CAN JUMP YOU GOT TO DO
SOMETHING WHEN YOU'RE RUNNING
FROM THE POLICE. WHEN HE WAS
BORN IN NINETEEN FORTY ONE IN
SHREVEPORT LOUISIANA HE MOVED
TO OAKLAND CALIFORNIA WITH HIS
FAMILY SEVEN YEARS LATER. HIS
ORIGINAL LAST NAME WAS GLADNEY
BUT HE CHANGED IT TO MONIQUE
BECAUSE HIS GRANDMOTHER CALLED
HIM THAT WHEN HE WAS A KID. HE
WAS FOURTEEN WHEN HE AND HIS
MOTHER MOVED TO BERKELEY. AND
AT A LOCAL MOVIE THEATER HE
WANTED DANCE CONTEST BECAUSE HE
WAS DOING A STOMPING DANCE THAT
INVOLVES SLAPPING AND PATTING
THE BODY LIKE A DRUM THE HAM
BONE. AND HE REALIZED HE LOVED
THE APPLAUSE HE WORKED WITH
PRIOR. FROM NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT TO TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
HE WAS ALSO KNOWN FOR HIS
COLLABORATIONS WITH RED FOX AND
EDDIEMURPHY. END AS ONE OF THE
WRITERS ONE HIT COMEDY SHOWS IN
LIVING COLOR SANFORD AND SON
AND GOOD TIMES. YOU MAY HAVE
ALSO SEEN A FEW CULT CLASSICS
INCLUDING RICHARD PRYOR SPILLS
WHICH WAY IS UP. AND BUSTING
LOOSE AND PAUL MOONEY PORTRAYED
SINGER SONGWRITER SAM COOK IN
THE BUDDY HOLLY STORY. HE
CHRONICLED HIS PARTNERSHIP WITH
PRIOR IN HIS TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVEN MEMOIR BLACK IS THE NEW
WHITE. WELL HE IN PRIOR WE'RE
OPPOSITES IN MANY WAYS MOONEY
NEVER DRANK DRANK OR DID DRUGS.
THEY SHARED A STRONG CONNECTION
HOWEVER IN COMEDY ENDING CUT
HARD EDGED COMEDY- I RECALLED
GOING TO SEE ONE OF PAUL MOONEY
STAND UP SHOWS. MAYBE FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO IN BERKELEY AND AS I
MENTIONED HE WAS KNOWN FOR VERY
INCISIVE COMMENTARY THAT
CONFRONTED RACISM I DON'T
REMEMBER NOT LAUGHING MUCH AT
THAT SHOW AND BEING VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE. I THEN SAW HIM
AGAIN ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO AT
THE BERKELEY BLACK THEATER AND
AT THAT SHOW AFTER OF COURSE
WATCHING HIM ON THE SHIP HELLO
SHOW AND ASK A BLACK DUDE AND
SUCH. FIVE MUCH MORE
APPRECIATED HIS COMEDY AND I
WAS MUCH LESS UNCOMFORTABLE
THOUGH HIS PURPOSE WAS TO MAKE
ME SO. BUT IT DID MAKE ME THINK
A GREAT DEAL. LATER GENERATIONS
OF BLACK COMICS GRAVITATED TO
MOONEY IN THE EIGHTIES HE
OPENED FOR EDDIE MURPHY ON HIS
ROCK SHOW. AND WHAT I WILL END
WITH IS AFTER MOONEY'S DEATH
DAVE CHAPELLE ON NPR'S MORNING
EDITION CALLED MOONEY SIMPLY
THE BEST THAT EVER WAS THANK
YOU FOR JOINING IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN IN
GERMAN- IN MMORY OF MR PAUL
MUNI- INDIVIDUAL THAT I MET
SOME. FORTY PLUS NOT PLUS FOR
FORTY YEARS AGO- DOING STAND UP
COMEDIAN OR COMEDY- LA AS A
GERMAN LAST WEEK IN THE MEMORY
OF FRED CALLAWAY I MENTIONED
HIS FACILITY IN LA THAT'S
LEGENDARY THE REGENCY WAS THAT
FACILITY SERVED ASKED A BLACK
COMEDY AT ACT THEATRE FOR
ALMOST TEN YEARS WERE RISING
STARS FROM ALL ACROSS THE STATE
LET ALONE THE NATION CAME AND
PERFORMED ROUTINES ON A REGULAR
BASIS MR MOONEY WHO WAS ALREADY
A STAR WOULD GRACE THE STAGE.
PERIODICALLY AND HE WAS JUST
AMAZING AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BERKELEY SAID HE WAS
UNAPOLOGETIC ABOUT HIS COMEDY
HE USED THE REALITIES OF RACE
AS A PLATFORM TO. EDUCATE AND
BRING FORTH LAUGHTER BUT AT THE
SAME TIME MAKE FOLKS
UNCOMFORTABLE AND MAKE PEOPLE
THINK ABOUT THE RACISM IN THE
PREJUDICE THAT EXISTS IN THIS
COUNTRY AND AGAIN HE WAS
UNAPOLOGETIC ABOUT IT. AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY STATED
I'VE- WATCHED HIM PERFORM MANY
NIGHTS FOR WHITE AUDIENCES
WOULD WALK OUT. IN HIS ONLY
RESPONSE WOULD BE I HOPE MY
BLACK FRIENDS THAT YOU'RE
AFRAID OF ARE OUT THERE STILL
IN YOUR CAR RIGHT NOW. AND BUT
THAT WAS PAUL AND ONE OF HIS
FUNNIEST ROUTINES AS MANY FOLKS
MIGHT NOT KNOW WAS ONE OF THE
LEGENDARY ONES ON SATURDAY
NIGHT LIVE IF YOU REMEMBER SOME
FORTY YEARS AGO. IT WAS RICHARD
PRYOR. AND CHEVY CHASE DOING
WORD ASSOCIATION HE WROTE THAT.
SKIP IN ITS MEMORABLE IT'S
MEMORIAL IT'S ONE OF THE MOST
TALKED ABOUT SKITS ON SATURDAY
NIGHT LIVE PAUL HAS ON MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKSHIRE WAS A-
COMIC GENIUS. AND I APPRECIATED
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET TO KNOW
HIM OVER THE YEARS AND AGAIN.
WHAT YOU SAW WHAT PAUL MOONEY
WAS WHAT YOU GOT AND HE HAD NO
FILTER BUT AT THE SAME TIME HE
SPOKE FROM HIS HEART HE SPOKE
FROM THE REALITY OF THE WORLD
THAT HE LIVED IN AS A BLACK MAN
IN AMERICA ANY USE COMEDY TO
HELP TELL THE STORY. OF THE
RACISM AND DIVISION AND
DISPARITIES THAT EXISTED SO I
ASK THAT WE JOURNEY MEMORY OF
A- GREAT CALIFORNIA GREAT
AMERICAN AND A GREAT
HUMANITARIAN THIS BALL MOANING.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
SENATORS PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO THAT
HE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. MEMBERS WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE BILLS ON CALL SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THOSE NOW.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH S. R.
THIRTY. WE'RE GOING TO WAIT A
MOMENT.
MEMBERS IF YOU'RE READY
WE'RE GONNA LOOK THE CALLS ON
OUR FIRST THREE ITEMS. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE LET THE CALL
ON PAUL ITEM TWENTY TWO S. R.
THIRTY NINE. ALAN I GORGEOUS I.
DALLY. GROVE JONES. MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S. NIELSEN WELL. FIVE
THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW WE'RE MOVING ON THE
S. P. SEVENTY NINE FALL ITEM
NINETEEN FROM SECRETARY. ALAN I
MCGUIRE I SKINNER I WELL. MARCH
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE SIMPLY
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. NOW
MOVING ONTO SR FORTY. FILE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR LEYVA
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
OB TO MEMBERS. ALAN I. MCGUIRE
I. MELINDA'S SKINNER. SKINNER
HI. HIGHS THIRTY NINE KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PUT. PASSES%
WE'RE GONNA FALL FOR THE CALL
JUST FOR A MOMENT MEMBERS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE LET'S
LOOK TO CALL ON A. B. FOR
THIRTY NINE FALL ITEM THIRTY
SIX. POLICE CALLED OUT TO
MEMBERS. ALLEN I. PORGES. ADMIN
I. JONES LLEVA. I MCGUIRE I
SKINNER HI THE- PRICE THIRTY
TWO NO SIX THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS IF THERE'S NO FURTHER.
BUSINESS BUSINESS CENTER CENTER
I CAN SUGGEST IS COOLER. THANK
YOU SO MUCH COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE THANK YOU
SO MUCH OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION
IS SCHEDULED FOR THURSDAY JUNE
TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AT NINE AM THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL. MMHM ON THURSDAY AT NINE
AM.